it's hard close good race in it you know
it's very entertaining really close it's
the cutting trust it's the me versus you
it's the physicality of it all it's the
close racing it's the the gamesmanship
the getting your elbows out getting
stuck in aggressive it's fast and that's
why we've all must have crowds in every
weekend I'm a rookie and it's all about
getting amongst there and it's all about
the racing you need to know when to be
aggressive at the right point but you
also need to know when to turn the other
cheek and roll with the punches when it
comes to I've got to be very wary of who
you've got around you teammate
personality what cars are in what
attributes their car was strengths their
car got most mistakes made will be in a
race situation you need experience you
need to be fast you need to be clever
wiping place not just enteric erasing
you don't really have any time to take a
breath because there's if you're on
someone front of work out their
weaknesses you've got someone your tail
trying to work out your so you're pretty
busy out there all the time
I've got a racing game problem yeah I'm
contributed
I've got my god way little setup at home
I've got my chair and my pardon
everything and it's become a real
problem